WELCOME BACK, JOE BIDEN IS
BACK IN WASHINGTON AFTER HIS
FIRST PRESIDENTIAL TRIP ABROAD.
WITH A HIGH STAKES SUMMIT WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
BOTH LEADERS SAY THE 3 HOURS OF
FACE TO FACE TALKS REMOTELY
POSITIVE, BUT WITHOUT ANY BIG
BREAKTHROUGHS.
WHILE THERE WERE AREAS OF
POSSIBLE COOPERATION, SEVERAL
CONTENTIOUS ISSUES REMAIN.
MATTHEW CHANCE HAS MORE FROM
GENEVA.
>> WE THE HISTORIC SUMMIT
STARTED IN CHAOS.
KREMLIN AND WHITE HOUSE PRESS
PACKS JOSTLING FOR POSITION.
THE RUSSIAN AND AMERICAN
PRESIDENTS THEMSELVES INSIDE.
>> I HOPE OUR MEETING WILL BE
PRODUCTIVE.
>> IT'S ALWAYS BEEN BETTER FACE
TO FACE.
>> IT'S ALWAYS BETTER TO MEET
FACE TO FACE, HE SAID.
THE VOICE TREND OUT BY THE
SCUFFLE.
BUT THE UNDIPLOMATIC START FOR
THIS CONTROVERSIAL MEETING
STARTED THE TONE.
>> CAN YOU CHARACTERIZE THE
DYNAMIC BETWEEN YOURSELF AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN, WAS IT HOSTILE
OR FRIENDLY?
>> [INTERPRETER]
I THINK THERE WAS NO HOSTILITY,
QUITE THE CONTRARY.
WE DON'T SHARE THE SAME IDEAS
IN MANY AREAS, BUT BOTH SIDES
SHOWED INTEREST IN ONE ANOTHER
AND FINDING OUR OPPOSITIONS
CLOSER TOGETHER.
>> BUT THERE IS SOME THINGS
THAT THE PRESIDENTS WILL NEVER
AGREE ON.
LIKE THE APPALLING TREATMENTS
OF ALEXEI NAVALNY, THE
OPPOSITION LEADER WHO WAS
POISONED THEN JAILED DURING HIS
ANTI-CORRUPTION CAMPAIGN SHUT
DOWN.
THE CYBERATTACKS, WE'RE ALSO A
MAJOR THOUGHT IN THE
RELATIONSHIP SIDE, SOMETHING
PRESIDENT BIDEN WANTS STOPPED.
SECONDLY, THROUGHOUT THESE
CONVERSATIONS, DID YOU COMMIT
TO CEASING CARRYING OUT CYBER
ATTACKS ON THE UNITED STATES?
DID YOU COMMIT TO STOPPING
THREATENING UKRAINE SECURITY,
DID YOU COMMIT TO STOP CRACKING
DOWN ON THE OPPOSITION IN
RUSSIA?
>> [INTERPRETER]
AS WE SAID TO SECURITY, WE
REACHED AN AGREEMENT CHIEFLY
THAT WE WILL START NEGOTIATIONS
ON THAT.
I THINK THAT'S AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
[END OF TRANSLATION]
>> IT WAS ONLY A PARTIAL ANSWER,
AND THE CONFERENCE MOVED ON.
BUT TO HIS CREDIT, PRESIDENT
PUTIN TOOK MY FOLLOW-UP.
>> THAT'S CORRECT, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR COMING BACK TO ME
SIR.
2 PARTS TO THE QUESTION, FIRST
ONE, DID YOU COMMIT IN THESE
MEETINGS TO STOP THREATENING
THE UKRAINE, REMEMBER THAT IS
WHY THE SUMMIT WAS CALLED IN
THE FIRST PLACE?
AND THE 2ND PART OF THE
QUESTION, AND 3RD PART, DID YOU
COMMIT TO STOPPING YOUR
CRACKDOWN AGAINST THE
OPPOSITION GROUPS INSIDE OF
RUSSIA, AND BY ALEXEI NAVALNY?
>> [INTERPRETER]
I DIDN'T HEAR THAT PART OF THE
QUESTION, MAYBE IT WAS THE
INTERPRETER WHO.
--
>> ON UKRAINE HE RESTATED THE
KREMLIN'S LINE, AND THAT
EXISTENCE ON RUSSIAN SOIL IS A
THREAT TO NO ONE.
AND REFUSED TO SAY ALEX
NAVALNY'S NAME.
>> WE [INTERPRETER]
THIS PERSON KNEW THAT --
HE SHOULD HAVE NOTED THAT AS A
PERSON WHO IS CONVICTED 2 TIMES.
I WOULD LIKE TO UNDERSCORE THAT
HE DELIBERATELY IGNORED THE
PREMISE OF THE LAWS
[END OF TRANSLATION]
>> SO FAR, THERE IS NO SIGN
TH